[Music]
all right thanks everybody for coming so
I'll be giving an update on so I could
learn on what we've added in 0.20 and
what we're gonna add in the future so a
quick question here who your users like
so I could learn on a regular basis
okay most people so I'm gonna do like a
very brief overview and then I'm kind of
going to go through a laundry list of
different features we added and what's
the rationale behind these features and
sort of what's important to us oh wait I
want to see yes all right so what's I
could learn so I could learn is the
machine learning library in Python so it
implements lots of different machine
learning algorithms were supervised and
unsupervised learning mostly together
with tools to Junie's per algorithms to
build machine learning pipelines and to
evaluate algorithms go very briefly over
the basic API the data representation
nets I could learn uses internally is
always an umpire array which is usually
a dense array of floats that we call
capital acts where each row corresponds
to one sample each column corresponds to
one feature in supervised tasks the
target output for regression or
classification is usually called
lowercase Y and it's the one-dimensional
numpy array while you can give penisy to
frames to basically everything as I
could learn it will immediately convert
it to an empire array and so if you have
like Eugenius data types or column names
or anything like that
cycle learn will mostly just completely
ignore it so the second workflow in
second learn for supervised learning is
as follows so all the models in
scikit-learn
are implemented in Python classes and
these classes encapsulate both the
training procedure and the prediction so
here let's say I want to build a random
forest model I instantiate this skill F
object
and this is when I would set any hyper
parameters like how many trees I want in
the forest and so on and then I call fit
on the train data store this
representation of other features and
this is targets or a classification
outcomes and I call fit method with both
of these this will build the random
forest model and store the trees and I
see a life object if I want to make
predictions using the model I used to
predict method and just give it my numpy
array of data most supervised models or
all this provides models also have like
convenience function to just score how
well the model does on a new data set
this uses accuracy by default for
classification or square for regression
and internally just makes predictions
and compares the predictions against the
test set I'm going to go through this
pretty quickly because it seems you're
all pretty familiar so I mentioned the
fit method so all models in cycle learn
have the fit methods we call the general
like Python class or the API of this
type of object estimators I could learn
so this could be any supervised or
unsupervised model they all have a fit
method they all get the submitted
representation acts and for supervised
models they also get some target
variable Y then there's two other
methods are really important imagine or
I predict predict is if you want to
predict some outcome or target variable
in classification regression or
clustering and the other important
method is transform which is used
whenever you want to create a new
representation of your data so basically
these create something like ax these
create some sorry these create something
like Y these create something like a new
ax so this is in pre-processing
dimensionality reduction feature
selection and feature extraction so this
is sort of the basic model API there's
also a bunch of other tools as I
mentioned to help you select models and
both modeling pipelines one of the most
commonly used ones is a great search CV
which does
Furniture tuning using exhaustive search
with NASA kress radiation here's an
example of how this might look like this
is sort of my hello world it was I could
learn a little bit so you have some data
set given as x and y you split it to the
training test data set you define a grid
of parameters you want to search over so
here we're doing us RBF support vector
machine RBF kernel support vector
machine for classification there's two
parameters one at UNC in gamma so we
specified as grid as a dictionary where
the keys are parameters we want to tune
and the value set of values we want to
try and grid search will try all
possible combinations of these
parameters the cool thing here is that
well the cool thing is that this is all
done automatically the other cool thing
is this grid object here again has the
same estimator API as all the models so
this grid object so this line actually
only construct the object and then to
build to run the grid search and to
build the model you actually call fit
fit now runs the grid search with
cross-validation will select the best
parameter settings and we'll rebuild the
model using the best premier's found on
the whole training set and then you can
use this grid object just like any other
classifier and call like score predict
so running this grid search looks
exactly like applying any other model in
terms of the methods you will produce
the other tool was very commonly used
it's important cycle ordinance the
pipeline's pipeline allow you to chain
several transformation with any
arbitrary model this is important to
encapsulate like processing chains in
particular the pre-processing of your
data so so here's an example if they
have two transformations say scaling
your data and imputing missing values
and then you have a classifier for
pipelines it's important that all steps
are transformers apart from the last
step the last step can be anything so if
I call fit on this where will happen is
it takes your input data ax
and your target spline fits the first
transformer t1 say a scaling of your
data then users you want to transform
your data to x1 say the scaled version
of your data then fits the second step
say imputation call t2 here then
transforms x1 + 2 x2 the imputed data
and then finally call fit on a
classifier so this kind of processing
chains are very common and basically
anytime you apply any machine learning
algorithm you're likely to have this
kind of processing chain and then if you
can predict it will just call
transformer all the things in sequence
and in the end call predict on the last
model on a chain this allows you to mate
to ride very 16 code it also allows you
to encapsulate the whole processing with
that in a single object here this pipe
object that you can then easily store so
here's what it looks like in code just
if I want to make a pipeline out of say
scaling and support vector machine I can
easiest way to do this is calling us
make pipeline function I give it
centered scalar which does zero mean
variance and the kernel support vector
machine and now this pipe object
contains both of these steps if I call
fit it'll scale the data then fit to
support vector machine and scale data if
I call predict it'll scale the data the
test set and then call predict on a
scale test set I can also use this in
grid search which would which allows me
to search the parameters after model but
also of any pre-processing so if I have
like parameters in my pre-processing
like how many features to select or
something like that
I can also search in a grid search over
any parameters the pre-processing might
have the only thing you need to sort of
take care of is that when you specify
your grid of parameters to search over
you need to specify what step in the
pipeline you want to adjust the
parameters so here by default two steps
are named by the lower case class names
so here I have an SVC and I want to
again adjust the parameters seen gamma
so I have to tell a grid search to use X
VC which is the lowercase class name of
the class I want to adjust double
underscore C and then it will know to go
to the step as you see in the pipeline
and it just seen gamma there so who here
has not seen this before everybody seen
this okay so this is what you should do
every time you use I could learn and I'm
not joking cool that was just sort of a
small refresher on sort of best
practices and the tools that we have now
I want to talk about 0 21 sorry 0 20 dot
0 this is the current release that came
out in October I want to say we will
have back fix release a 0.20 dot one
hopefully the next week so a lot of the
things in this release are really about
making things easier for users so these
are not like amazing new machine
learning algorithms these are tools to
make the things that you do all the time
as easy as possible they're not as easy
as possible yet but I think we're moving
it right direction so one of the things
that I found endlessly annoying so far
is that we couldn't use the one hot
encoder which does dummy encoding of
variables on strings before it only
worked on integers now it works on
arbitrary Python objects basically so if
you have data represent it in this way
say categorical variable that's male or
female and integer variable 1 3 2 and
you can call now one hot encoder and it
will encode both of these with dummy
variables and so that's kind of
something that you really wanted and
it's kind of embarrassing we didn't have
that before but now we do so that's good
another thing that goes sort of
hand-in-hand was this was is the column
transformer to call transformers the
first
we really integrated with pandas in a
meaningful way the cotton transform
allows you to apply different
transformations to different columns in
your data set so usually you have at
least two types of columns say
categorical continuous variables and you
usually want to have different
pre-processing for these different types
of columns you want to have like
different scaling different implications
for energies and so on so here this is
an example on the infamous Titanic data
set let's say we focus on five features
here there's two continuous features or
numeric features called agent fare and
three categorical features embarks X and
P class and so now for America features
I create a pipeline that says oh I want
to do median imputation then scale to 0
mean unit variance and there's a syntax
error dad so this will basically create
a processing pipeline that's for the
continuous variables for the categorical
variables let's say I want to fill all
the missing values with the string
missing and then I want to do a 100
quarter or dummy encoder so now what the
conference form allows us is to use
these on different subsets of the
columns so here I specify the columns so
numeric features are these guys so these
are column names in a panda's data frame
categorical features are these guys
again column names and in a pandas
dataframe and these are transformations
that want to apply so now the produced
different pre-processing steps on the
different columns are encoded in this
preprocessor and now I can build like a
final model by putting this preprocessor
in a pipeline with like some classifier
and so now to see a life object encodes
the whole workflow doing all the
different coding scaling and so on and
this is really helpful if you have
different kinds of features in your
dataset or different columns that you
want to treat therefore
and yes you can you can also specify
let's say if I want to use all the
columns I can just specify tome Eric
features and then do say what I want to
do with the remainder so by default the
remainder is to drop all the features
that are not named but I can also do
something else was the remainder where I
can say these are the category features
do something with the categorical
features and the remain in there are
numeric so just for a reminder user
numeric transformer or just keep them as
they are questions about this and
contact Lea it's pretty simple but it's
like I think a very useful tool sure
yeah sure you can do any type but you
you need to declare what the
transformation is you want to apply
while you can use its function
transformer to change the date or some
formatting and you need to specify
whereas manually which columns you want
to apply it to we're working on sort of
trying to make this more automatic to
see which columns are which type but the
problem is if someone has if there is an
integer column there's basically no way
to know if this is a continuous or
categorical unless user tells you to
tells you which of the twitters Oh going
with the theme of like easier
pre-processing the other thing that we
added is the power transformer which
basically allows you to change the
distribution of in inputs in a flexible
way so the idea is if you have a skewed
distribution as shown up here linear
models in your networks are often in
somewhat sensitive to the distribution
of the data we added the power transform
in the Box Cox transformation and Joe
Johnson transformation which are both
power transformations meaning they take
the data to some power lambda and they
estimate as lambda 2 so that the data
afterwards looks as Gaussian as possible
and so you can see these here these guys
who are sort of much more normal this is
a generalization of the trick of taking
a log so very often you as
pre-processing you might take the log of
your data so they
it's scaled in a nicer way this is a
generalization it automatically finds
out what is the right transformation you
should apply in this family of power
transformations we also improved with
missing value treatment in several ways
so we now allow castling missing values
through all of the scalars we have a new
thing called a simple in future which
replaces the previous computer which is
like a slightly different to face and we
added a missing values indicator which
allows you to add additional binary
indicators whether something was
computed or not usually data is not
missing at random so if you impute the
missing value you usually want to
preserve the information that something
was imputed because yeah very often this
is useful information and so this
missing indicator allows you to encode
this even more pre-processing now of the
target with the transform target
regressor this allows you to do a
transformation say log to the target so
this power transformer was transforming
your data the transformer target
requester allows you to do
transformations on the target so why
would you want this let's say you have
like a target that's skewed like this
you want to fit a linear model if you
lock transform it it might be easier to
fit a linear model but if you want to do
something like model comparison you want
to do the model comparison on the
original in the original data space
right so before you do any like
computing the MSE or something like this
or here in this case to be an absolute
error you want to actually transform it
back and so this transform target
regressor allows you to transform say in
to lock space then apply say linear
model and then transform back for
evaluation so then you can put this guy
in in a grid search and it will do the
right thing if you just apply lock to
your wise and then you do grid search
you
do great search in the logarithmic space
which is usually not about what you want
to do alright um another thing not
related to pre-processing this time then
I'm very happy about is he opened mal
dataset loader Obama is a platform that
I'm done by some people in mostly in the
Netherlands and Germany and I'm
collaborating with it hosts a bunch of
different datasets so right now there's
about 20,000 different datasets there it
also allows you to specify machine
learning tasks on these and uploads
different the results of different
machine learning algorithms run on these
data sets and so they have like I don't
know eight million results so this is
quote and there's like open L Python
which is library to interface with this
but in scikit-learn we also want to
interface with this just to get all the
good datasets so we added this function
called fetch open em al that allows you
to fetch any data set that's on this
platform by name and you can if you want
your datasets to be easily available you
can upload your own data sets to open
them how and then anyone that has cycle
or install can get your datasets by just
saying fetch and then the name we
previously had something like an
interface to a similar platform called
ml data the problem is that the person
hosting ml data doesn't respond to
emails anymore and the server is
basically down
and so we're deprecating fetch ml data
and we now have fetched up memo and the
person that made Haynes's is now in my
lap and so i make sure that he actually
maintains it
another cool thing that we added this is
really amazing work done by the team in
Paris is Loki Loki is a replacement for
the Python multi processing pool so this
is basically a retic replacing a
relatively low-level thing in Tison to
do parallelism problem was that this
pool was not very stable and we ran into
a lot of issues with parallelism in
particular and unlike Windows you had to
do if name equal main in all of your
scripts if you want to use parallelism
and if you were on OS X you might get
random crashes because of the blast that
Apple uses and how the people that write
Python and the people that write Mac OS
don't agree on what POSIX means and if
you or if you have libraries using open
P so if you're using like cameras or
tensorflow or extra boost they use open
P for paralyzation if you put this
inside a cycler in grid search and say n
jobs equal to 5 to do a grid search in
parallel before this would crash now
runs and so that's it's pretty nice
so another thing that we added is global
configuration and working memory so
there's now a thing called the config
context or set config which allows you
to set global flags and cycad learning
and two flags that are these are mostly
for efficiency so the two that we added
so far is assumed finite and working
memory I think soon finally finally we
had already a little bit longer turns
out that if you have a production system
a lot of if you call to predict on a
model very often and the model is very
fast in cycle learned most of the time
is spent checking if the data is finite
and usually if you have a production
system you know what the data is like
and if you say assume a finite equal to
true I will not check if the data is
finite and sometimes that gives you like
2x speed-up or even more of course if
there's like an an in the data then
it'll give you garbage trees or it'll
give you an an as a result the other
thing that we just added is the working
memory which is mostly for if you want
to compute big distance matrices or if
you want to compute nearest neighbors
between many samples if you if you have
like a million data points and you want
to compute the three nearest neighbors
you like theoretically we want to
compute a million by a million distance
matrix but that might kill your RAM and
so this working memory tells you don't
use more RAM than this and so it will
chunk big computations into smaller
pieces so that basically your machine
doesn't start swapping and so right now
it's like the default is a gigabyte but
you can set it to more if you want and
so basically the bet that this way you
can do chunking that's appropriate to
the memory you have this is right now
mostly used in distance computations but
it's probably going to be used more
widely in cycle or in the future
the reason why we need this is because
it's very hard to actually detect
automatically if your ram is getting
full so it's very it's basically
impossible for us to detect whether your
arms getting full and so we need to tell
you need you to tell us in advanced how
much ram you we were supposed to take a
couple of efficiency improvements
gradient boosting classifier now has
early stopping which means that you can
specify a validation fraction it will
hold out a validation set and then it
will stop adding more trees when the
validation set score doesn't improve and
the same thing for su casa gradient
descent and all the similar models we
have like a validation fraction and this
allows you to do early stopping on a
validation set another thing I think
will be great for users is that we added
a glossary which is basically a patient
documentation that says explains what we
mean when we say worse so there's a lot
of slang we use in psy could learn and
this explains all the slang hopefully
there's some things missing let us know
then we'll add it and all of our
documentation we're now linking to this
glossary to explain all the different
things that we like what the words mean
we also change some default though I
don't want to like go over these in too
much detail you might notice that if you
upgrade you see a bunch of deprecation
warnings and I want to talk about this
in a little bit so the thing is that a
lot of people are using cycle and a lot
of people are using cycler in production
and so if we change to behavior there
the behavior of your production code
will change most people don't like that
so what we do is we basically have a
contract with our users that says we
will never change our code without
warning you first so whenever you have
any it's like of learn code
it will do exactly the same thing in the
next version unless it warns you that
it's not going to do that and will
always warn the user for two versions
which should give you one or two years
depending on how slow we always release
us to adjust your code so for most users
these deprecation warnings are like a
little bit annoying but if you have a
preemption system running they're really
important because they tell you you need
to change your code now or either the
behavior will change or the code will
break and so the alternative to doing
these deprecation warnings would be to
immediately change the behavior or
immediately break the code or not to not
to do either of them never change
anything
I don't think both of either of these
options are very good and so we do this
like deprecation cycle which usually
takes like a year or two or two versions
of cycling and yeah so as an end user as
usually it's relatively fair to ignore
those unless you have code that you that
you need to have been running like if
you have experiments that you possibly
want to run again in a year you meet me
to make sure you address these warnings
because otherwise the code might stop
working a year and like one of the
things maybe I'll go back to this is for
example we used by default
cross-validation used to be three full
cross validation if you didn't specify
it will be five fold cross validation in
the future recurse know introduced three
fold cross validation in five folders
like a more accepted default and so we
want to change this but we can we are
not doing changes now we're going to
yell at you for two versions if you
didn't specify which cross validation
you want it and in two versions in 0:22
we're gonna switch the behavior and
similarly for random forests right now
the default is to have ten trees in the
random forest which makes no sense at
all to me and so we will change its
behavior to 100 but we're not going to
change this now because we don't want to
break your code if you for whatever
reason wanted to use 10 and so will yell
at you if you use the default for
versions and then in two versions we'll
change it to a hundred whoa
so these were all the features that are
in the already released version I'm
gonna talk a little bit more about now
about things that are coming up so first
things that we already merged into
master so these will definitely be in
the next release and then a couple of
things that are work in progress that
will hopefully be in the next release
where and by release I mean 0:21
not 0.21 so that will be in the next
major release in like half a year not in
the release next week so one thing that
I'm like and excited about because maybe
because I wrote it is we have new
virtualization for trees so one of the
nice things about decision trees is that
you can easily plot them unfortunately
the easily so far was a little bit
hindered by reliance on a library called
graph with to layout the trees that's
very hard to install on lots of
operation systems and so now we
basically wrote our own visualization or
rather I copy and pasted it from Stack
Overflow and so we can just use use
matplotlib
and we don't have to rely on graph twist
which is like a really package C library
so other things that we work on right
now basically there's a for the first
time ever there's a draft roadmap so
right now it's a draft we're going to
publish set of final version or a
consensus version on a website pretty
soon you can already check it out in a
wiki this is all the things we want to
work on like a longer term so because
there's like a lot of things going on
and we have thousands of open issues or
at least a thousand open issues and it's
very hard to track and so this is sort
of trying to give a big-picture overview
of what's happening with so I could
learn these days or and what will happen
in like the year or two years to come so
one of the things that we'll have
happen is that we're dropping Python 2.7
support in the next release actually
metal lip already dropped right into
point seven support and numpy will stop
adding features for a Python to release
at the end of the year so now is really
a good time to go to Python 3
we are also dropping Python 3.4 support
so you should really work on Python 3.5
at least otherwise all your libraries
will not work any more soon or at least
you will not get updates with the new
features so if you work at a company and
you're running Python to tell them
that's a very bad idea
another thing that I I kind of like and
excited about even though it's like not
a big machine learning thing is we
haven't work on a new representation and
you dunder score wrapper this is what
you get and you do put a note book if
you like write a model it'll print out
some text if you have like a pretty
standard thing like a great search
object here with the pipeline this is
actually an example I gave you earlier
like doing grid search with the pipeline
with a standard scaler if you look at
this now it'll it'll print this I don't
think this is very pretty
in particular the indentation makes no
sense it's been this way since I joined
so I could learn like seven years ago
and I didn't like it then I didn't like
it now so I told my postdoc to fix it so
this is what it looks like now and now
it's like still a whole bunch of text
that's like possibly a little bit hard
to see all of them because it plus all
the parameters but at least the
annotation makes sense and you can see
there's a grid search object there's a
pipeline object in it and it has steps
and these are the two steps and so I
think that I makes much more sense than
this which made no sense at all then we
even went to step further and using the
new configuration context or you can
also use set conflict if you want to
globally change it we can say print only
they've changed parameters and then the
representation will be this and so here
this is actually very compact and you
can actually see what this is supposed
to mean instead of like totally
overwhelming you with all of the
fermentation details so this is what we
had before this is what we're gonna have
them and hopefully this will be like
less scary and will actually tell you
something about the models you're
working with again this is more on a
theme of like trying to make it
accessible trying to make it user
friendly and yeah really making easy
tasks easy the other thing we're working
on is our dimension loci which is a new
processing tool processing multi
processing pool developed by the team in
Paris this will allow us to do more fine
grained parallelism so right now so I
could learn only does parallelism on a
very coarse scale so for example in
random forest it will bloat each tree on
a different core this is one of the
reason our grading boosting is so slow
because we can't build a single tree
across multiple cores we can't do fine
Grail parallelism right now because of
the way how Python multi processing
works with this new processing pool
thing we can we'll be able to use OpenMP
and we're right now trying to add this
to k-means but hopefully we can add this
to basically all models and have
scikit-learn and be like a true multi
core library which unfortunately it is
not right now or not as much as we would
like another thing and we'll integrate
is there's a library called imbalance
learn which allows you to resample
datasets for technical reasons or for
API reasons right now you can't easily
resample datasets in pipelines and
basically we will integrate the API from
this library imbalance learn in some way
and this will allow us to do subsampling
and over sampling of data inside
pipelines which would be nice
I mean doesn't tell me how many slides I
have oh good so and the final in your
future that I'm working on right now is
basically integrate even better with
pandas so I talked about this column
transformer that allows you to apply
different transformations to different
subsets of the day town the problem is
once you fit a model say I have my I do
my pre-processing here or and then maybe
I do some logistic regression or
something I want to get my coefficients
out I want to know what the coefficients
mean right now there's no way for this
thing to tell you what to cook like what
thing in the original data the
coefficient corresponds to so I want to
really get this gate feature names thing
which works in some places in
scikit-learn but won't work here which
will tell you well the first feature is
this thing the second feature is this
thing and so on so you get the
correspondence you get a semantics of
where do these features come from what
do these coefficients mean yeah because
right now basically it's this con
transformer is very black box and
pipelines similarly are very black box
it's very hard to see what do these
different features in the model actually
mean all right so this is all I had for
today this is a book I wrote with Sarah
Ito if you're interested in learning
more about scikit-learn
you can check it out it has no formulas
in it only code that was sort of one my
goal with this is this really targeted
programmers if you want something more
advanced there's also the lecture I'm
giving here at columbia applied machine
learning is on my columbia website with
like there are 20 videos or something of
me talking about ii learn and other
machine learning stuff
you